hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith we've got a love story
of a different kind in today's best
picture close up as the filmmakers
including a writer director Spike Jonze
appear at the academy to discuss the
creative process of her mr. Theodore
Twombly welcome to the world's first
artificially intelligent operating
system we'd like to ask you a few
questions okay the initial idea of the
film you know the philosophy was
creating this warm tactile world sort of
a heightened world we already live in
where everything is nice and comfortable
and with design becoming more relevant
the world and with technology making our
lives easier sort of making this utopian
world where you have everything you want
but theater were still lonely and he's
still longing in that sort of
combination of pop with melancholy was
became our sort of fundamental driving
point the Los Angeles that Spike had
written wasn't as dense downtown was
populated or as progressively urban as
what we wanted to it to be so we knew
we'd have to collage it with another
place and so it happened that we found
in Shanghai an area that's only come
from a farmer's field since 1990 and it
progressed much faster than our urban
downtown did so combining the two just
made sense they were kind of seamless
there's something that feels
good about sharing your life with
somebody we found the early on the
joaquin could kind of just take you
through the whole scene even if he he's
just listening he couldn't if you just
hold on him he couldn't kind of track
his character that way so you didn't
have to we'd have to cut away to these
povs of things like that spike and I
wait I think we were talking a lot of
how do we want to cut away or if you
want to cut away and in the beginning it
felt it felt phony I think we tried to
come up with with with point of views
that we could do even filmed a lot of
them but but in the end I think you have
no choice and you just have to focus on
what what you actually legitimately can
look at them and that was mainly cooking
or sugar touch you how would you touch
me one of the references was last tango
in paris and the intimacy between those
two actors in that apartment and and
just how strict down the acting is how
natural and have just like years feeling
these humans breathe in this moment in
their life and so that was this
reference at you know that i was talking
with Joaquin about and then he came in
and he know we put him in high waisted
pants until type something grow
moustache and had glasses on him and red
shirts and he's like oh I thought this
was we were going for Last Tango in
Paris and I was like I think we could
try and do both we can have it be
stylized I still go for that kind of
honesty and intimacy I used to be so
worried about not having a body but no I
i truly love it I think scarlet
initially did think it was gonna be a
voiceover Samantha needs to have like us
she's created without any insecurities
and he's self doubts she gains fears
almost as that are contagious from him
when we talked about like being able to
strip away all those things that's when
she realized actually this is not just a
voiceover is the real character need to
be prepared and
and created want to see what happens
behind the scenes at this year's Oscars
visit Oscar calm for complete coverage
and look for more inside the Oscars
updates coming soon thanks for watching